[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
the deadly highland park fourth of july
shooting to the residents of highland
park and surrounding communities
this murderer will be brought to justice
and i am truly sorry that pistol and
blue were not declared
protecting australia is important the
fbi steps in as amber heard faces
perjury charges in australia plus
missouri versus dejuan ferguson it was
the defendant that caused christian's
death duwan has no motive to kill his
son
none hear closing arguments from both
sides and later what message britney
griner has for president joe biden just
days after her russian trial begins law
on crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmark at least
seven people are killed and dozens more
injured after a gunman opened fire at a
chicago area fourth of july parade
it happened in highland park illinois
about 30 minutes north of chicago just
after 10 o'clock monday morning
investigators say nearly 40 people
ringing in ranging in age from 8 years
old to 85 years old were treated for
gunshot wounds at a nearby hospital
among those who were killed a former
preschool teacher and a grandfather
after an hours-long manhunt officials
took 22-year-old robert creo cremo the
third into custody he was arrested after
being named a person of interest in the
case but has not yet been charged
investigators believe he opened fire on
the parade from a nearby rooftop later
investigation shows he likely used a
high-powered rifle to carry out the
shooting although officials believe he
obtained the weapon legally at a press
conference on monday illinois governor
j.b pfitzer
addressed the families of the victims
and called for stricter gun control laws
the families of six individuals woke up
today to join a community celebration of
our nation's independence
they will go to bed tonight
less than whole
there are no words for the kind of evil
that shows up at a public celebration of
freedom
hides on a roof and shoots innocent
people with an assault rifle
there are no words i can offer to lessen
the pain of those families who will no
longer associate the 4th of july with
celebration
but instead with grief it is devastating
that a celebration of america was ripped
apart by our uniquely american plague
a day dedicated to freedom has put into
stark relief
the one freedom we as a nation refuse to
uphold the freedom of our fellow
citizens to live without the daily fear
of gun violence
joining us today is co-host terry austin
and florida state attorney dave
ehrenberg dave charges haven't been
filed yet but as the palm beach state
attorney what charges do you see here
brian good to be with you there'll be
multiple charges of first-degree murder
that's the most serious crime there's
evidence of premeditation here
but the problem is in illinois they have
a moratorium on the death penalty so the
most that this guy could get would be
multiple life sentences
and in florida if that happened then he
would certainly be eligible for the
death penalty but in illinois
it looks like that's the charge and
that's what he's going to be facing yeah
like you said in multiple so while there
is no death penalty in moratorium since
2011 they can go back to back to back
and run those consec rather than
concurrent terry police are already
pointing to the person of interest
social media and supposed rap career
were there red flags that weren't caught
and maybe a lesson to stop future
shootings here you know there were
multiple red flags on social media and
that poses really a unique set of
challenges because
just from the sheer volume of postings
on social media the fact is the local
state and federal authorities have to
investigate all of that and clearly his
posts were cringing he basically talked
about multiple mass shootings he
was a rapper and his songs and his
lyrics talked about that and i do think
that it should be used against him if
ultimately he is tried and it gets into
evidence but i think it's really hard to
decipher social media and to figure out
whether or not it's a real threat
hopefully the authority will be able to
do better in the future with those types
of postings yeah that's crazy i heard
that local law enforcement were there on
the ground on the streets but they're
not patrolling the rooftops because why
do that it's crazy how these different
methods are being employed for these
mass shootings well
at a separate fourth of july celebration
two police officers were shot and
injured when a gunman opened fire in
philadelphia it happened just before 10
o'clock monday night during a firework
display on the ben franklin parkway
investigators are still searching for
the suspect whose gunshots struck two
police officers one in the head and the
other in the shoulder as gunshots rang
out the crowd of the 4th of july
celebrators began running down the
street
both officers were treated at a nearby
hospital and have since been released
right now the shooting is still under
investigation
prospective jurors are filling out
questionnaires now for the trial of
george wagner iv in ohio's pike county
massacre wagner is accused of helping
his parents and brother plan and carry
out the murders of eight members of the
rodian and gilley families in april of
2016. the eight were found shot to death
in their homes in four locations most
were shot as they slept the george's
brother jake has already pled guilty to
the murders and will spend the rest of
his life in prison and has agreed to
testify against his family members their
mother angela also pled guilty and has
agreed to testify as well billy wagner's
trial could start later this year george
wagner says he's not guilty because he
didn't actually pull the trigger in the
crimes but prosecutors say george wagner
was involved in the crimes every step of
the way the case is considered one of
ohio's largest criminal investigations
jury selection will begin august 8. law
and crime will be there to bring you
continuing coverage of the trial
still ahead on law and crime daily
closing arguments are presented in the
trial of dejuan ferguson
but first does amber hurt still face
perjury charges overseas why the fbi is
now involved in the investigation
[Music]
welcome back amber hurd's been under
investigation for allegations of perjury
in australia for more than 18 months law
and crime's angela levy is here with how
the u.s law enforcement is helping the
australians
yeah brian the fbi is assisting the
australian government with this
investigation and has been for quite
some time some internet journalists have
actually been talking about this and now
we've learned it is indeed true and they
are
assisting with an investigation into
allegations about whether or not amber
heard perjured herself
where are things at with pistol and
booze star wars
that was australian senator glenn sterl
at a hearing in october 2021 asking for
an update on an investigation of amber
heard
why is it taking so long that's all i
want to know in fact do i need to have a
senate inquiry on it the saga dates back
to july 2015 when heard was charged with
illegally importing her dogs pistol and
boo into the country in violation of
australia's biosecurity laws the dogs
she shared with johnny depp were
smuggled into the country without the
proper documents and without being
declared and quarantined in violation of
those laws the following year heard
pleaded guilty to a lesser charge of
falsifying travel documents and recorded
a video with depp by her side australia
is a wonderful island with a treasure
trove of unique plants animals and
people it has to be protected
the perjury investigation started in
2020 after statements made by johnny
depp's former estate manager kevin
murphy at depp's libel trial against the
sun in the uk
murphy testified that heard pressured
him to give a false statement to
australian authorities about how the
dogs entered the country and that he had
warned her the dogs didn't have the
proper paperwork to enter australia how
can it take 12 months we know the
evidence that was there then they came
to celebrities thought that they're
above australia's biosecurity laws and
we know barnaby joyce or minister joyce
had his little meltdown and good on him
okay whatever
uh no this is cut and dry
what's taking so long
well senator
it's only cut and dried if we can get
a conviction and we can only get a
conviction if we work with our partners
at the afp
and that's where the fbi comes in the
fbi has offices in australia of course
and around the world so when allies ask
for assistance in criminal
investigations they gladly assist
there's no word yet on when this
investigation could be complete
we've been told many times that it is
ongoing and there will be no further
comment and amber heard's team did not
respond to my request for a comment i
sent them an email over the weekend
brian thanks angenet dave perjury and
probably hearsay for the favorite legal
terms during the deaf and heard trial do
these australian perjury charters seem
like they have merit to them
yes it seems like she did lie but then
is the juice worth the squeeze i mean
this is a seven-year-old case this is
not exactly capital murder
and although you don't want to treat a
celebrity any better than anyone else
you also don't want to treat them any
worse than anyone else you have to
wonder
would the australian government be going
after another person if her name was
amber smith would they go after her or
is just because she's a famous celebrity
who just lost a defamation case in the
united states i think it's the latter so
maybe they just want to move along to
the next matter yeah we'll see how this
plays i i tend to agree with there with
the
amber smith analogy now terry can the
fbi's participation in perjury charges
in australia have repercussions for
heard in the united states
well i don't think the fbi's
participation is going to have any
repercussions and i also don't think
that the case in australia will have any
repercussions it's all about whether or
not she accurately filed the paperwork
as far as bringing those dogs into the
country the biosecurity the issues here
for perjury as far as amber is concerned
really relate to that defamation and if
anything brian we could very well see
the uk
going back after amber heard because in
the virginia defamation case she
actually said about the 7 million
divorce settlement something very
different than what she said in the uk
she said in the uk she paid all of that
she couldn't really say that in virginia
so we might see something else happening
to her back in the uk they could bring
those charges up against her so we'll
see what happens yeah it sounds like a
lot of potential fines pledges or
donations up for amber heard now
angenette herds legal team also filed
some documents in the fairfax defamation
case before the holiday weekend what
were those
they filed a post-trial motion brian
asking the judge to set aside the
verdict or order a new trial they
believe that the judgment was excessive
they believe that she did not commit or
was not liable for defamation because
they said they believed that she was
actually abused they also brought up an
issue with a juror and said that
basically this juror they believed was
born in one year but he was born in
another and they want the court to
investigate alright see how those play
out thank you everyone for contributing
coming up on law and crime daily the
trial for wnba star brittany griner
begins in russia
plus a verdict is handed down for dejuan
ferguson will a missouri jury find the
man guilty of his son's murder
[Music]
welcome back a verdict decided just
hours after closing arguments were
presented in the case of dejuan ferguson
a missouri man now convicted of killing
his nine-year-old son christian in the
early 2000s christian who had a rare
disorder which prevented his body from
processing protein properly was just
nine years old when he went missing the
boy needed constant medical attention as
his disorder interfered with his ability
to walk and talk prosecutors say
ferguson failed to provide his son with
proper medication for more than two
years the day christian disappeared june
11 2003 ferguson left his home with his
son and stopped to use a pay phone
moments later he called 9-1-1 to report
someone had carjacked his running suv
with christian inside
the vehicle was found hours later just a
few miles away and christian's body was
never found
after just two and a half hours of
deliberation jurors found ferguson
guilty of first-degree murder and child
abuse resulting in death just before the
verdict was handed down prosecutors
presented their closing argument saying
ferguson deliberately killed christian
in this case we have years of
deliberation
every time he didn't give him his
medication
every time he didn't bother to feed him
he knew what he was doing
he didn't do it
that is a deliberate choice he made
because christian was an inconvenience
he didn't want to be bothered with
and then that night
going into his room
that was a deliberate choice
picking him up from his bed
and taking him into the other room
that was a deliberate choice
and whatever struggle occurred in there
whatever he did
a little christian
that was absolutely a deliberate choice
and then he took him from the residence
did something with the body
and then planned a cover-up
ferguson defense attorney argued
ferguson had no reason to kill christian
if it's possible christian's alive it's
not guilty
if it's possible that christian was
kidnapped it's not guilty
if it's possible that christian died of
his disease
that's not guilty
state has to prove beyond a reasonable
doubt that dejuan caused the death of
christian
anything less than that is not guilty
the one has no motive to kill the son
no
there's no
life insurance policy
no financial
windfall
the state's grasping at straws for a
motive
and what they're trying to say isn't
supported by any evidence
and it just doesn't make sense
ferguson's conviction carries a
mandatory life sentence without the
possibility of parole
terry we know the verdict so what do you
think nigeria hung their hat on in
reaching their decision
you know i listened to that
prosecution's closing and it was in line
with the evidence of the case they hung
their hat on the fact that the father
had nothing to do with the son he really
just ignored him he didn't give the
medication and the motive contrary to
what the defense is saying is i just
don't care i don't want to be bothered
that's a motive you don't have to have a
financial motive and i think here it was
very clear that the father just ignored
christian nine years old he was relying
on him to take care of him at the end of
the day the jury came to the right
decision and they said you are
responsible with this kind of motive
now dave ferguson sentence is mandatory
but we can guess there will likely be an
appeal were there any issues that stuck
out that you think the defense can win
if they made an appeal
no and as a prosecutor i
think that they're going to be grasping
at straws to try to overturn this
verdict it looked like the only question
amongst the jurors was whether it was
first degree or second degree murder
the uh the defense may try to say well
the prosecution didn't meet the weight
of the evidence the burden of proof here
where you have to show beyond a
reasonable doubt that he is the one who
killed his son as opposed to well it
could have been you know lack of poor
lack of nutrition or a million other
factors but in the end i thought that
the evidence was pretty compelling he
was a bad dad didn't care about his son
and he is the reason why his son
died right well like all cases they're
going to be an appeal we'll be
interested to see how this plays out
whether it's final or there's an
overturn of course law and crime now
will be there to cover both situations
when we come back an american faces
trial on the other side of the world
wnba star brittany greiner writes a plea
to the white house in hopes of getting
help to come home
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily in
international news the trial of united
states wnba player brittany griner
begins as she calls on president biden
for help while detained overseas
back in february griner was arrested and
detained in russia after cannabis oil
was allegedly discovered in her luggage
at the airport the united states has
since said griner is wrongfully being
detained a reiner known mostly for her
career as an american basketball player
for the phoenix mercury also plays for a
russian basketball team in the off
season last friday greiner's russian
trial began a judge there ordered
greiner remain in the country until it's
over which could last until december on
monday greiner penned a handwritten
letter to president biden urging him not
to forget her the letter reads in part
quote i'm terrified i might be here
forever in reference to the fourth of
july holiday grinder wrote quote it
hurts thinking about how i usually
celebrate this day because freedom means
something completely different to me
this year if convicted griner could face
up to 10 years behind bars in russia
dave greiner's charges have been
questionable along with her detention is
there any reason to believe that this
trial will be legitimate
no just like the war in ukraine is not
legitimate she's being used as a
political pawn by vladimir putin they
have an authoritarian state and they're
very anti-lgbt
so the judge is going to make the
decision in this case and i can imagine
the judge is probably not the most
progressive of sorts and their system is
different than ours ours is an
adversarial system both sides give their
evidence and uh give their case here
it's an inquisitorial system where the
state acts as the investigator creates a
case file and that's the basis for the
verdict i don't expect justice in this
case yeah if anything i'm expecting
hopefully the president steps in and
maybe a trade is made but what that
trade may be i'm not quite sure terry
your reaction to griner's letter do you
think it will move the administration to
do more in returning her
i do think biden is taking this letter
very seriously and it's not the only
letter he's gotten he's gotten letters
from lgbtq groups and women's groups and
and groups all across the country she's
pleading for her life and she's hoping
that biden takes her as a priority you
know it's really sad you mentioned brian
that she was there playing the russian
premier league and she's doing that in
the off season to make extra money so
she really is part of that community in
a sense she's been there you know
several years doing this and it's really
a shame that she's been stopped for this
sort of what we would say is a minor
violation
she faces if she's convicted up to 10
years in a penal colony and you know
they could slap on additional charges
and they could even keep her longer and
i think she's very worried and she's
worried for real reason so i am hoping
that biden looks at this and does
something to help her out yeah maybe
this is the end of american players
playing in russia that could be a next
step as well well thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you